c'est un sujet de tension depuis
plusieurs années à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
campagne d'emploi de la fac pour la
rentrée 2010 est est critiqué par les
enseignants et les membres du personnel
administratif pour montrer leur
mécontentement une cinquantaine de
personnes a protesté ce mardi 6 décembre
à midi devant l'ufr santé à moutier aux
bretons ne avant le conseil
d'administration de l'ubs est est ce qu
on propose six postes pour les billes
hats et 6 pour les enseignants
chercheurs
alors qu'on a perdu plus de 200 postes
en deux ans donc la situation n'est plus
tenable
les personnels sont en burn out en
dépression selon la direction de
l'université un budget nous maîtriser
sur l'emploi pourrait entraîner un
déséquilibre de 7,5 millions d'euros
dans les caisses
à partir de cet équilibre on est capable
de garantir notre autonomie et à partir
de cette autonomie
on est capable de se projeter dans une
stratégie et cette autonomie ça veut
dire évidemment première responsabilité
de présenter un budget en équilibre
les manifestants pourraient se réunir à
nouveau avant les fêtes de fin d'année
si le dialogue avec la direction ne
reprend pas